meanwhile 6 hours into a live stream
guess in the comments my fastest growing
platform right now so a lot of LinkedIn
answers the answer to the question and
it's not even
close I day trade attention and build
businesses Legacy is greater than
currency I'm a pure bread entrepreneur
for real for real for real like
documented
really thinking about streaming all day
just seeing like the true day today I
think there's something cool about this
in the background for 8 hours straight
and I'll unmute and try to give like
little tidbits this is very alpha alpha
alpha not even beta yet but I think this
could be very valuable for everyone even
the worst acting citizen on this call
I'm prepared to help them get a job not
at bayner media that pays them more than
they get paid right now at bner media
before they get fired as long as they're
communicating to you and me think about
that you know [__] say that is Kate
it's the safest agency in the world but
it's completely predicated on how much
people talk to us to fix [__] not to
each other to talk [__] oh I like that
that was it right there I love you happy
holidays I can't wait to see you in a
couple weeks fer Nation what is good it
is time again for podcast with friends
where I bring people from different
worlds doing cool [__] and we just kind
of chop it up I'm excited about this
episode I'm obs obsess with Tik Tok live
I think all three of you should build on
Tik Tok live everybody doesn't go live
because they think they have to do
something I think you should go live
while you're eating lunch oh that's what
I
do I do live sometimes on Tik Tok where
it's just me eating and talking to
people for like two hours everybody
heard on Twitch if you're trying to
build your [__] cuz I know you are
please pay attention to that Tik Tok
live to me right now is one of the best
Arbitrage is one of the best ways to day
trade attention we're on mute yeah wait
what what do you want
meetings # test okay cuz when we do it I
want to like always go back and be like
this is when you know what I
mean I'm about to do some beend stuff
right now I think this is like a
potential evolution of daily be and if I
could figure out how to unmute enough
that there's value and I if I can figure
out what can be playing when we're on
mute maybe it's old podcasts music up
incoming artists that could be cool so
people are discovering new artists while
they're watching we'll figure it out but
I'm excited I have a lot of passion that
we have to stop making videos that
people don't want to watch this
phenomenon of making commercials has to
finally hit ahead in our industry nobody
on this twitch Channel right now nobody
in these streams like they do not want
to watch these boring 30 second videos
and you know this DEA as a senior
marketer they're freaking expensive
wasting money in any shape or form and
marketing is a bad idea running regular
television commercials on network and
cable at the costs that they are today
is
asinine this this is the truth I mean
you're seeing it meeting after meeting
after meeting to recap a little bit this
how Victoria and Hannah and Marcus my
chief of staffs were just planning
trying to take care of like some things
hold on one second I run a twitch stream
on mute now my whole day in my office
and snowflake Just Ask Gary do you have
a Boston presence I guess for the
company I just wanted to answer him and
tell him that we do not because I hate
the Patriots and now let's go back to
this awesome meeting with Telly
everybody buy a
telly
I really got to pee my pants oh yeah so
let's bang this out so I can go
pee if this is something you were doing
how would you tackle it and advise to
just get them to see that color is a
valuable tool for wellness an ungodly
amount of podcasts and social media
content is the most feasible way for
someone who doesn't have lots of dollars
to get a message across it's
storytelling and I think that comes in
Vlog form streaming form podcast form
and then social media Tik Tok Instagram
YouTube Twitter like it's content baby I
really do appreciate you I'm incredibly
humbled that any of you would just join
and chill out with me for the day means
a lot to me I have a funny feeling the
community in here is going to get very
friendly and awesome will probably be
muted given the nature of the meetings
I'm
having to recap everybody what's going
on here I'm just testing something new
like a daily B meets ASMR thing here
that I think could end up being really
cool and I hope this um shows you how
the sausage is being made like f is
saying here and I think it's going to
really matter like daily V really showed
people but I think this is like even
more real life and so I have a feeling
that this 129 people is eventually going
to be 12,000 people like I think I can
really build this but I'm just testing
this the first time I'm really doing it
we've been talking about it so I'm
excited so thank you for being here so
what I'm about to do now is hang out
with a bunch of people virtually who own
an nft from be friends that gives them
access to that and I'm excited about it
guess in the comments my fastest growing
platform right now so a lot of LinkedIn
answers Tik Tok the answer to the
question and it's not even close
Facebook gaining thousands and thousands
of followers a week I can't push all of
you enough towards Tik Tok live
meanwhile like it might be Facebook it
might be LinkedIn it might be Twitter X
like all of you are going to be better
at certain platforms than others cam cam
just ask how am I using Facebook I'm
posting on my Facebook page written only
is crushing literally transcribing words
out of my mouth typing them out hitting
post so you got to try different [__]
look what uh pack leader dog said I post
the same [__] on all platforms currently
time issue I totally get it and Facebook
has grown most by far you know why this
is how day trading attention works
there's still millions of people on
Facebook but almost every contemporary
modern Creator is not making content on
Facebook Supply
and
demand I don't know if all of you know
this but we've opened a restaurant in
VCR group called little Maven it just
opened it's in New York City and like
I'm Blown Away by the feedback we're one
week in for everybody who's a New Yorker
or if you're visiting New York for the
holidays please go check out little
Maven it's pretty exciting brother I'm
really glad you came I was really
excited to come here Priceless what you
get out of one hour of a of a dinner I I
couldn't agree more and in different
forms I'm aware that I potentially
tonight can bring value to people but
like it's people period I mean it
happens to be all the time from people
that are accomplished people that are
struggling people that are different you
know like I'm going to leave right now
and many of you might get the most value
not for me tonight but from someone that
said something here it's powerful people
it's very
powerful Wells Old Friends I wish him
well close a cough hit the nail had to
change the person keep a distance he can
tell